[Music]  pigeons still here yeah no matter what  we do he just won't leave the problem is  you're thinking like detectives no I'm  definitely not when you should be  thinking like a bird this is operation  saving private pigeon on my mark I will  turn on this fan gently startling our  bird due east into the file box canyon  where he will encounter Charles holding  two pot lids he'll bang them together  forcing private pigeon into the ceiling  there and out of the ceiling there where  he will be greeted by scary Rosa holding  a scary picture of an owl now he's  playing our game he'll be er left into  an upside-down garbage can propped up by  a hockey stick and connected to a string  that Gina is holding she pulls it he's  trapped and Terry releases him outside  Terry hates birds ok little friend let's  get you home to mama  [Applause]  you